so we begin with this breaking news
story out of guinea which we've been
covering for a few hours now president
alfa conde is reportedly being held by a
group of soldiers
there's been heavy gunfire near the
presidential palace in the capital
conocry the military has been deployed
on the streets and is urging people to
stay home
now a video has been circulating among
local media in guinea showing president
conde
being detained by army special forces in
the video conde is asked if he is was
tortured or mistreated to which he
responded
no
now let's show you where all this is
happening uh this is the presidential
palace in the calum business district of
conocry
where heavily armed soldiers have been
seen guarding the area the exact
whereabouts of president conde are
unknown
it was earlier reported he was near the
presidential palace
at hotel calum
joining us now on the phone is yusuf ba
a journalist in guinea joining us from
conakry yusuf uh bring us up to speed
with the situation when we spoke earlier
you reported that gunfire
was still ongoing in conocry what's been
happening
right now
um presently uh the situation's still a
confusion
shooting going on
just call another source now saying
there is negotiation going on between
the special force um some government
officer uh seems like president alfa
conde is in the hands of the members of
the special force
there's another picture just now another
journalist just called my attention tony
president falcon that was transported
into a trip um maybe to this particular
area
the minister of security office also has
been surrounded by the special force so
this has been confirmed
by by myself i've seen the special force
surrounding the ministry of security
office
and the situation is very very confusing
but negotiation is going on now maybe
this is going to be like another
situation another neighboring countries
we are negotiating so we've seen the
negotiations going on between co-leaders
and government officials right so maybe
this is the kind of thing that is going
on in guinea conakry
right uh unclear as you say as to where
the president is right now tell us about
the reactions of course this has been
happening in kalum which is the business
district of conakry it is sunday so
it wouldn't be as busy as it would be on
a weekday but there have been reactions
i mean people
are scared but they've been celebrations
i understand in some other parts of
conocry
yeah the veto area commonly called the
act of conor creed
the people have been dancing celebrating
uh they accept it's like they welcome
anything and they welcome all the social
media messages that is going around them
so it's very very confusing the other
area where you have uh supporters of
president
everybody's indoors everybody's think us
nobody's outside and a few people you
are seeing how to go into russia to get
food like bread and other food stuff
situation is very very confusing i'm
talking to you now everywhere i'm
standing
having journalists i'm the only
journalist standing around only tb5
journalists was around just now it's
like he's trying to escape from the
staff okay so a fluid situation thank
you yousuf for updating us on what's
happening in conocry let's bring in uh
west africa correspondents now nicholas
hack who's also following events for us
is joining us live from dakar uh yusuf
nick says there that there are some
sorts of negotiations going on as far as
president conde is concerned we don't
know what's happened to him or where he
is right now
just give us some context some
background to all this it's not the
first time there's an attempted coup in
guinea
what could have led to this latest
tension and unrest that we're seeing
well fully there's been growing
discontent against president alfa conde
ever since he tweaked the constitution
allowing him to run for a third term and
the outcome of this uh this election
that took place last november that was
contested by the opposition and civil
society actors and and they took to the
streets and in response there was a
heavy-handed reaction um according to
human rights groups and amnesty
you know security forces shooting live
ammunition towards protesters and so
ever since
that election there's been a situation
of instability it became the status quo
for guinea and alfa conde had just a
week ago
passed a new bill in the parliament that
irked a lot of people especially members
of the security forces where he
essentially allowed himself a pay
increase for the presidency and himself
and a pay decrease for civil servants
including members of the security forces
now the the gunfire that we've seen in
in kanakui the the the the
the battle that's been nicholas i'm so
sorry to interrupt you because we're
getting live pictures from uh state
television in guinea right now for the
rtg which is a state-owned television
and we see soldiers
uh on tv right now uh addressing it
seems the nation uh the picture is
frozen for for a second but hopefully
we'll get it back on they've been
delivering a statement uh it would
appear uh unclear who these soldiers are
but a number of them about what three
six nine ten nine ten soldiers on the
national tv in guinea right now uh
addressing the nation
uh this is of course
pointing to the confusing situation
let's try and listen in a bit and i'll
try to translate if i can
system
yes
okay let me just translate a bit of what
we've heard there
from that
army
commander not clear what his rank is but
he says
it's now time for guinea to unite it's
time for us to create a new constitution
which is capable of addressing the
country's issues
this is increasingly looking
like a coup d'etat nick nick hack with
these soldiers now appearing on national
television addressing the people of
guinea
that's right in fact there's been a
video circulating on social media where
we see uh members of the red parade uh
the presidential guard addressing uh
people addressing fellow soldiers to a
rally on their cause and in in that
speech
they explained that there were too many
deaths and that it's time to sit down
perhaps rewrite a constitution
adapted to the circumstances of guinea
talking about the situation in hospitals
and and at schools
essentially during the rule of alfa
conde
there's been a huge increase in the
economic prospects a country that's
wealthy in iron ore and exports have
been
increasing rapidly especially to china
russia and to europe but the
circumstances of ordinary guineans have
gone from bad to worse most people live
on less than two dollars a day they've
struggled through the economic pandemic
where there were heavy restrictions put
in place
and and may many people who live just on
on two dollars a day and that get by on
on on a day's wage well they weren't
able to to survive and also the
heavy-handedness of the security forces
and this sense amongst a portion of
guinea's population that they weren't
being represented by alphaconde remember
during the last election the office of
of
the united nations watch on genocide
pointed out that alfa conde should calm
down on this rhetoric his ethnic
rhetoric in this country where the
fulanis make up the majority but the
melinke from which he is uh from uh have
taken up a key position in the
government and security forces there was
growing division within um
society there okay we we've lost uh have
we lost it we still have those pictures
from uh rtg the national broadcaster in
guinea well they're leaving now
the people who were speaking from the
army unclear who's in charge right now i
i know you've watched a lot of the same
videos as i have nick
of these uh soldiers red berets who are
uh the presidential guard of course is
is it clear now who's in charge who do
we see in that video you think of uh you
know these soldiers speaking on national
television
well what's interesting is we've seen
the red berets the presidential guards
that are meant to protect the president
now holding the president under arrest
but we've also seen the elite special
forces that have been on the ground it
seems coordinating with these red berets
and and one name has been uh floating
around social media mamadi dumbayoo who
is the head of the special forces a
former french legionnaire who
came in 2018 um to to to to reinforce
these special forces and he's been
accused by the government who saw him
with suspicion of trying to move away
from the ministry of defense to gain
greater independence and seen as perhaps
a foe to the president but what's clear
in this message and this action that
we've seen of these these special forces
these armed forces that they feel that
the civilian rule or the
democratic way
isn't representing guineans and they
felt that they should take over power to
to bring what they believe is a new
guinea a feeling perhaps and perhaps
emulating what happened in a neighboring
country in mali where we've seen um the
the military takeover when there was a
popular uprising and popular protests
against uh the president there we have
to remember in fully that in guinea
there's been a
protest for the last year that that you
and i have been covering right in the
region protesting the rule of alfa conde
right and that may explain why these
emboldened soldiers took to to to what
they're doing right now let me just
remind our viewers nick of what we're
watching right now these are the latest
pictures coming to us from uh guinea
state broadcaster rtg
it is now past
5 p.m in guinea 5 12 p.m uh it's gmt
time no actually 5 12 p.m here in doha
so that's 14 12 p.m uh a gmt in guinea
and soldiers have appeared on national
television
addressing guineans and saying that now
is the time for guinea to unite and
create a new constitution
that would address the country's
problems as nick hack said there
this increasingly looks like a coup
d'etat against president alfa conde
and
this coup reportedly has been led by
lieutenant colonel dumboya
who
has been we understand speaking on
national television he said that borders
of the country have been closed and the
current constitution of guinea has been
suspended until a new one is created as
nick hack said this is not the first
time there's been a coup attempt in
guinea
unclear as to the extent of the success
of this one because we still don't know
the whereabouts of president alfa conde
nick stand by
we'll bring you in in just a second in
the meantime let's speak to mario
billowa
who's ceo of africa international media
group and she's joining us via skype
from paris i imagine the french watching
what's happening in guinea very closely
mariju given that it's one of their
former colonies and a lot of french
interests in that country
does this
coup or attempted coup
if we may call it that come as a
surprise to you
well uh
of course obviously it's very much uh
people are following very closely what
is happening here in in guinea
um
i must say
since election
uh
earlier this year uh the tension has uh
grown and it's it's not uh
it
did not become lower the tension and um
and the the situation in mali was also
in thank you something
and we
have been hearing of rumors of pool a
couple of weeks ago
and we
sort of it's always surprising that when
it really happens and
what we know so far is that the head of
the special force and specific buddha
had
an argument
yesterday with the minister of banks
this morning
uh and what we if we believed is that
he could not rally the
the all the security forces of guinea
and that he
was
mastering only the special forces but it
doesn't seem to be true but still they
could capture the president
they are they have the president in
their hands their custody but there is a
communique of uh of
of the minister of france saying well
they are still fighting
there is an attempted coup but it didn't
work
we are urging everyone so
unclear and clear right now even though
we're seeing these pictures of these
soldiers on national television which is
very often what
happens in in many african countries in
that region anyway when a coup happens
the soldiers go on tv and say okay we've
done this
we're now in charge but at this stage in
guinea it's unclear who's in charge or
whether the school has been successful
or not
the army in guinea
to what extent has been has it been
united around president conde that has
been many people would say his strength
in all these years as he's been in power
including during this controversial
third term
his has been his ability to maintain the
army uh around him surround himself with
a strong army but now these cracks seem
to have appeared within the military
yes and the special forces were
[Music]
let's say they are considered a malinki
indeed
and he was trusting them
but i must say
this third term
was not settled yet
unlike cote d'ivoire where there was
also a third term issue but you see
political life uh reviving uh lorenzo
came back they are
creating new parties new coalitions
[Music]
it's interesting that you talk about
ivory coaster and i want to ask you
something about that i mean uh there are
those who say the cynics anyway would
say that the difference between ivory
coast and guinea and the fact that allah
was able to go on with this
third term is that because he had the
backing of the former colonial power
france to what extent
is or was france still
supporting
alfa
conde yeah okay france is not at all
supporting alfa conde that's the truth
that the relationship is very different
with
with prayer president
as a matter of fact president alfa
connie
in france for over two years which is
unusual
he just came back from holidays in
church or some other places
not france anymore and
i know there were forces around him
trying to reconcile alfa conde with
france and even this week
meet with people
speaking about that said we cannot go on
having that bad relationship for
what can happen exactly
that was a concern okay so uh
i'll trust that the military special
forces knew that that president
conde won't have any backing from france
where if they do the coup okay
interesting uh to talk to you about this
of course we are in uh unknown territory
here as far as what is happening in
conakry and what's going to happen
mariju biloa thank you so much for
joining us